oui bonjour à toutes et à tous nous
parlons ce matin culture scientifique et
technique avec en effet christophe
simonet qui est aussi donc en charge de
la coordination de la compétition
robotique first une compétition
internationale bonjour christophe simona
une compétition internationale à
laquelle donc participent de jeune
martiniquaise et martiniquais bonjour à
toutes et tous oui effectivement
robotique first international c'est une
compétition qui regroupe 270 mille
participants dans le monde entier dans
88 pays
demain il y aura la martinique mais
également l'hexagone et la belgique qui
vont compétiteurs et pour la martinique
on a dix collèges qui se sont inscrits
puisque nous on s'est mis dans la
catégorie aux 9-14 ans et avec
l'académie martinique on a choisi de
privilégier de privilégier pardon les
collégiens alors pourquoi
quel intérêt pour pour nos jeunes alors
pour les jeunes c'est de là c'est ce que
j'appelle au carbet des sciences est ce
qu'on appelle de la pédagogie ludique
c'est un robot c'est quoi c'est un
matériel qui est programmé pour
accomplir un certain nombre de tâches
donc ça peut être dans la pour la
société civile en industrie en médecine
en injuste en industrie jeu les dix
militaires également exploration donc
c'est pour améliorer la pénibilité
diminuer la pénibilité du travail pour
les pour les humains et et faire faire
aux robots ce qu'un humain pourrait
difficilement faire pour l'exploration
spatiale ou des fonds marins par exemple
ce qui n'est pas sans poser quelques
problèmes
on y reviendra en fin d'entretien parce
que évidemment ça fait disparaître un
certain nombre de mes dix essais en crée
d'autres ont créé d'autres mais la
robotique est rentré dans les programmes
scolaires
donc l'intérêt l'intérêt pour nos jeunes
à travers ce type de compétition ludique
j'y reviens c'est c'est vraiment
apprendre en s'amusant et et et force
est pas forcément s'en rendant compte
c'est à dire que là depuis depuis
plusieurs mois puisque le concours a été
lancé le 15 novembre je reviendrai sur
les trois étapes les différentes étapes
clés de ceux de ce concours qui voit son
point d'orgue demain au palais des
congrès de madiana
ça a été de travailler en équipe à un
projet de recherche tout en faisant de
la programmation et en programmant
l'appareil que j'ai amené aujourd'hui
qu'à un mine storm v3 pour accomplir une
quinzaine de missions
enfin tout ou partie c'est aussi
stratégique demain lors du nul lors de
la compétition des matchs de robots très
bien alors on reviendra aussi sur le
thème de cette édition 2010 9
alors vous avez déjà évoquer quelques
aspects pour l'intérêt de ces collégiens
qui vont participer alors en martinique
c'est la troisième édition il y aura dix
équipes qui vont s'affronter de
différents collèges alors c'est bien
répartie sur l'ensemble de l'île enfin
je veux dire puisque sera peu près
représentés oui oui tout à fait oui on a
vauclin
on a fort de france bien sûr on à robert
vert-pré on à basse-pointe on a place
d'armes de lamentin voilà donc on a on
balaye à peu près tout
toute l'île très bien alors c'est ses
équipes donc ces dix équipes de deux
collégiennes et collégiens
il y aura une saine émulation c'est
aussi un des intéressés ça c'est alors
il faut démontrer un certain nombre de
qualités
vous dites les talents de programmeurs
voilà est en fait donc c'est un
véritable concours une compétition le
robot alors vous avez amené un exemple
les internautes qui ont l'image explique
donc à nos auditeurs en radio vous avez
amené un petit modèle voilà des types de
robots qui seront présentés qui tout à
fait à l'enchère alors le 15 novembre
chaque épi chaque équipe s'est vu
remettre son kit de compétition qui se
composait d'un tapis les 280 mille
participants ont le même donc le tapis
avec l'émission c'est la marque lego qui
est derrière derrière cette compétition
internationale donc c'est que du legos
du legos robot lemine storm v3 que j'ai
amené alors c'est quand même un petit
bijou de technologie puisque vous avez
alors vous avez un gyroscope à l'arrière
vous avez un sonar à l'avant un pour
calculer les distances
un capteur couleurs sur la droite il est
muni de deux moteurs et donc ce ce robot
ce robot type donc les équipes les
équipes ont toutes le même là en
martinique et après il est agrémentée
d'accessoires la gemmi un bras un petit
bras à l'avant et donc il va être
programmée par les équipes pour
accomplir il ya des 15 missions cette
année sur la thématique en orbite voit
donc
donc ça c'est la thématique annuelle du
concours et et demain lors du jeu du
robot qui est une des étapes comme je le
disais tout à l'heure c'est la fin en
fait du concours donc ça sera demain
après-midi et d'ailleurs les les
auditeurs et auditrices sont invités à
venir supporter nos jeunes c'est en
entrée libre en salon caraïbes
à partir de 13h30 demain après midi au
palais des congrès de madiana
alors quelques mots quand même parce que
dans tout ça ce concours se déroule pour
cette édition 2010 9 sur le thème vous
l'avais dit en orbite into arbitres en
anglais donc c'est sur fond
d'exploration spatiale
c'est pas un peu loin quand même des
bons de c'est vrai il ya le centre
spatial pas loin de chez nous à kourou
en guyane mais voilà c'est très con
cernant pour ces élèves de martinique
on est on est une planète on a envie sur
une planète donc donc ça nous quand ça
nous concerne tous puisque l'exploration
spatiale
l'objectif des objectifs de
l'exploration spatiale c'est aller voir
ailleurs pour mieux se connaître nous
mêmes c'est ce que tous les les
astronautes vous diront et la thématique
la thématique et le donc dans les étapes
du du concours les jeunes doit être
doivent travailler sur un projet de
recherche donc lorsqu'ils ont le 15
novembre dernier on a lancé au palais
des congrès de madiana également le
concours avec la remise des kits et à
partir de là ils ont dû réfléchir à un
projet de recherche liés à une mission
spatiale longue une équipe d'astronautes
part dans l'espace le soleil est à 150
millions de km une c'est une unité
astronomique
donc on est dans des distances énormes
des températures extrêmes
enfin on est dans un environnement hyper
hostile et donc nos astronautes si
demain ils doivent aller partir sur un
voyage long pour rejoindre une planète à
trois 3 ans de voyage comment ils se
nourrissent comment ils évacuent leurs
déchets comment ils respirent comment
ils boivent comment ils s'entendent
imaginez-vous partir pendant trois ans
voilà les gens du studio là on part
pendant mon partout les quatre pendant
trois ans est ce qu on sait ce qu'on se
tape pas sur la moi c'est ça qui sera
montré et démontré alors là les deux
voilà lé les projets de recherche il y
aura dix stands à 1 par ce collège
donc là je ne connais pas aujourd'hui je
ne connais pas les thèmes que chaque
coup les choisit de développer mais
effectivement
normalement ils ont soit améliorée une
solution existante
donc ils ont innové soit par halak en
inventant soit par en améliorant c'est
quelque chose qui existe alors sur le
déroule
de cette compétition donc demain à
madiana donc les équipes vont
s'affronter au qu'est-ce qu'il ya
pourquoi en fait c'est une phase de
qualification pour une deuxième
voilà quelqu'un alors les le challenge
et surtout la récompense au bout
demain demain ils vont demain ils vont
passer alors demain matin le grand
public n'est pas n'est pas invité ces en
huis clos ils vont passer devant trois
jurys donc un jury qui va évaluer les
valeurs fondamentales esprit d'équipé
cohésion de groupe
comment comment est-ce qu'ils ont
travaillé en équipe comment ils ont fait
un atout un atout ou un avantage des
différences des différences de
connaissances comment ils ont travaillé
ensemble ça c'est vraiment en filigrane
de toute cette compétition qui n'en est
pas vraiment une
voilà c'est tout le monde gagne
l'intérêt c'est de participer
et c'est vraiment l'objectif c'est le
c'est le fun et le sérieux ensuite il
passe devant un jury projets de
recherche donc le projet ils vont
présenter leurs solutions
quelles qu'elles soient liées à une
mission spatiale longue
donc là il passe devant 2 deux
scientifiques devant un jury de chaque
jury ce sont des binômes et il ya un
troisième jury sur la technique du robot
comment ils ont programmé
là encore comment ils ont travaillé
ensemble sur pour quelles solutions ils
ont trouvé pour accomplir quelles
missions très bien auront on termine
alors on rappelle juste le rendez vous
grand public donc concernant cette
compétition robotique first is here en
martinique
donc va demain venez les encourager à
13h30 au palais des congrès de madiana
c'est en entrée libre
et donc il y aura tout l'après midi donc
des matchs de 2 minutes 30
en face à face mais pas l'un contre
l'autre ils ont deux minutes trente pour
accomplir un maximum de mission et
engranger des points merci christophe
simonet directeur du café des sciences
et donc coordonnateur de robotique first
martini que le petit temps je ne vous
avais montré il fonctionne n'y a pas
assez de place dans notre studio pour
qu'on en fasse la démonstration mais
enfin voilà les internautes en ont pu le
voir bonne journée à toutes et à tous